I felt that Apple for the last decade  has not been as effective of marketers  people think but it's been hidden  because they're the best product and you  see it because you see way too many  people consider Android and youth  culture when that shouldn't be the case  it's that they're not winning on  relevance as much as people think they  might be you know I think there's this  big bad game of relevance and  consideration that is very classic  marketing jogger that television and  above the line vanilla sentences for  brand positioning are unable to achieve  it means that the brands that are  winning are quite effective in social  media marketing or on their product and  they don't have to be effective in TV  commercials and above the line branding  and the brands that are losing market  share are betting the farm on above the  line branding and TV executions and it's  just black and white and the only  enigmas are the ones that have the  product is so much better